[Music]
now in actuality the substance that
knows exists earlier than its form or
its notion determines shape first
substance is the as yet undeveloped in
itself or the ground and notion in its
still unmoved Simplicity and therefore
the inwardness or the self or the spirit
that does not yet exist what is there
exists at the as the still undeveloped
simple and immediate or as the object of
the picture thinking Consciousness in
general
cognition because it is the spiritual
consciousness for which what is in
itself only is insofar as it is a being
for the self and a being of the self or
notion has for this reason at first only
a meager object in contrast with which
substance and the consciousness of this
substance are richer the disclosure of
Revelation which substance has in this
Consciousness is in fact concealment for
a substance is still selfless being and
what is disclosed to it is only the
certainty of itself at first therefore
only the abstract moments of substance
belong to self-consciousness but since
these as pure movements spontaneously
impel themselves onward
self-consciousness enriches itself till
it is rested from Consciousness the
entire substance and is absorbed into
itself the entire structure of the
essentialities of substance
and since this negative attitude to
objectivity is just as much positive it
is a positing it has produced them out
of itself and in so doing has at the
same time restored them for
consciousness
in the notion that knows itself is
notion the moments thus appear earlier
than the filled or fulfilled whole who
is coming to be is the the movement of
those moments in Consciousness on the
one hand the whole though uncomprehended
is prior to the moments time is the
notion that is there and which presents
itself to Consciousness is empty
intuition for this reason Spirit
necessarily appears in time and it
appears in time just so long as it has
not grasped its pure notion that is has
not annulled time it is the outer
intuitive pure self which is not grasped
by the self the merely intuited notion
when this ladder grasps itself it sets
aside its time form comprehends this
intuiting and is a comprehended and
comprehending intuiting time therefore
appears as the destiny and necessity of
spirit that is not yet complete within
itself the necessity to enrich the share
which self-consciousness has in
Consciousness to set in motion the
immediacy of the Inn itself which is the
form in which substance is present in
Consciousness or conversely to realize
and reveal what is at first only inward
the in itself being taken is what is
inward that is to vindicate it for
Spirit certainty of itself
paragraph 801 is rather long and there's
a lot going on in it which will have to
unpack but we can say that what we're
doing here
is moving from substance or you know
thingliness
through the
Spirit grasping itself in time through
time through history and then
interestingly
moving beyond it annulling as he's going
to say tilgen is the the term there a
knowing time for itself and what we get
is
more and more complexity as we move from
substance Through Time into the pure
notion and at each of these states we do
have the notion or the concept but early
on it's less developed so Hegel is
telling us you know where we've gone and
what still actually has to happen in
this absolute knowing section and we saw
that
a little bit earlier we raised time and
we raised actuality vehicle now he says
in
actuality in vehicle kite the substance
that knows
exists earlier than its form or its
notion determined shape it's Gestalt
there are previous gestaltin right and
then he tells us what he means here by
saying for substance is as yet the
undeveloped in itself and we've always
seen that in itself just by itself all
right there's going to be more going on
we have to unpack this
and so we can say well what is substance
four and we're going to say that it's
for Consciousness and self-consciousness
but we'll come to that in in just a
moment he goes on and says it is the
ground right grund and notion concept
in what state in the state of yet
undeveloped uh still unmoved Simplicity
therefore he says the inwardness
or the self of the spirit that does not
yet exist but it exists potentially it
exists
further out
in time once we actually have time once
we actually have movement through time
and we should also say in history in
human time right so we don't want a
substance that is just unmoved
Simplicity we want we don't want
something that's purely simple that we
can just like goggle at oh isn't that so
cool you know no no that's not what
we're looking for and don't get misled
by hegel's use very heavy use later on
in this paragraph of intuition on
showing to think that it's just a sort
of grasping without Concepts because I
mean it's very conceptual
um
the the simple substance we don't want
to rest in that so he goes on and he
says what is there
exists
as the still undeveloped simple and
immediate
so what is there what has existence is
Da right
is the verb IST is the you know uh
conjugated form of that uh third person
singular sort of abstract you know it
being there
by the way there's going to be a lot of
stuff where you're like oh this sounds
kind of hi to Gary and we'll talk about
that in just a moment but that's that's
with the the substantiality right now
what is there exists is the still
undeveloped
you know unfulfilled simple and
immediate
or as the object of the picture thinking
Consciousness in general so you know
picture thinking we encountered this
back in the religion section well we've
encountered picture thinking or
representation throughout the
phenomenology each stage uh you know
engages in a bit of picture thinking a
bit of the philosophy of the
understanding as he'll call it a little
bit uh later on in a different work in
the lectures on the philosophy of
religion as we've talked about many many
times
it's inadequate
grasping of its own object and of
Consciousness and self-consciousness
knowing that object the spirit has not
yet attained selfhood in this even
though it works through
solves as it moves into time as it moves
into history as it's motivated by
recognition
so he goes on
and he says cognition now cognition here
or kentness not a term that Hegel
actually uses a lot in the phenomenology
and why is he using it here well because
air kentness we could say is one mode of
of grasping of understanding here he
doesn't seem to mean it in the sense of
conceptually grasping things right vicen
true Vision knowing is going to be
conceptual or through the notion and air
kentness uh understanding cognizing
knowing in in that sense of the term is
you could say lesser or is less
developed so he says cognition because
it is the spiritual consciousness for
which what is in itself only is right
what is in itself
could be more than just what it is in
itself but it's being treated as it's
allowing itself to be treated as it's
treating itself as just being what it is
again substance in this kind of
pejorative sense so he goes on and he
says
um is only is insofar as it is a being
for the self
right
and a being of the self now notice here
so being for the self right we were
going from the in itself to the four
itself and that self is spirit that self
is is grasping itself now through
determinate situations what we're going
to see in the next paragraph talked
about is experience right
uh particularization
so for the self
but immediately following this
um a being of the self
so for itself of the self these go
together and here he brings up the
notion
and he says
um
cognition has for this reason at first
only a meager Armin right poor an
impoverished object gen and that is the
substance right so grounded notion and
still on move Simplicity not not nothing
wrong with that but it's just not all
that it could be for us it should be at
this point in the phenomenology after
having gone through so many dialectics
now he goes on and he says
in contrast with which substance and the
consciousness of this substance are
richer so there's a danger of us just
looking at looking back at substance in
our cognition of it our cognition is
poorer the substance itself is richer
this is what's going to be reversed
right we're going to move from that
Dynamic into something better that we
already have moved into that
so he goes on and he says now here's
where again
all this being there talks on cyticarian
this is going to sound kind of high to
Gary and to you as well and we should
always remember too Heidegger did come
after Hagel and Heidegger certainly did
read Hegel because Heidegger talks about
Hegel at many points Hegel is one of the
last great metaphysicians Heidegger
actually does a lecture course a very
short one unfortunately on hegel's
phenomenology of spirit he only gets to
the self-consciousness section I wish he
would have gone further but he does talk
about him in other places now what's
going to sound Heidi Gary into
the disclosure or Revelation which
substance has in
this consciousness
is in fact
concealment
so how does that sound heideggerian well
you know uh truth as this Primal alethea
a
um putting things into prominence taking
away the veil you know
um taking them out of forgetfulness
putting them right there in front of us
and with every
um making something prominent there's
also a hiding concealment that goes on
at the same time you never have pure for
Heidegger you never have pure alethea
you never have pure revealing now
revealing here for Hegel not alethea it
is actually
um you know oftenborough the word that
we oftentimes will translate as
Revelation like you know when you talk
about the revealed religion the open
Baris
often Baron
um so uh it's not exactly the same thing
as what what Heidegger is saying and
it's not exactly the same vocabulary but
the revealing the showing is correlative
to a hiding or concealment for morganess
right for borgenheit
um to you know put something uh Under
Wraps you could say so what's going on
the disclosure of Revelation which
substance has in this Consciousness is
in fact concealment why because the
substance is so to speak getting in the
way it is doing the concealing the
substance is still selfless being so
it's not truly spirit yet right what is
disclosed to it is only the certainty of
itself and you might say well wait wait
a second there how the hell does it have
certainty of itself if it doesn't have a
self well that's what Consciousness and
what spirit is contributing to the
substance as it's bringing it along you
might say there's more here than spirit
is actually understanding
so he goes on and he says at first
therefore only these are the abstract
moments of substance belong to
self-consciousness so now we've got
Consciousness and self-consciousness
being brought in here and he says sense
these as pure movements spontaneously
impel themselves onwards so it's it's
not just that Spirit you could say
drags substance and its moments along
these moments each of them has has its
own dynamism its own drive and it is
propelling itself now each of them is
involving Consciousness and
self-consciousness to be sure
and now we're getting into time
we're getting into zeites
and indeed development and history
so you know this sounds pretty good
right that's part of the hegelian uh
whole stick the dialectic and he says
self-consciousness enriches itself so we
go from poor to richer right enriches
itself till it is rested from
Consciousness the entire substance all
that there was there before and absorbed
into itself the entire structure of the
essentialities of substance okay this is
alphaben this is sublation being carried
out by self-consciousness in conjunction
with Consciousness some
self-consciousness not the you know
earliest one of the self-consciousness
section not even the you know completed
uh uh you know forms coming after the
Master Slave dialectic but the
self-consciousness that we saw
playing such an important role seeking
itself out in the reason section trying
to Grapple with the ethical substance uh
doing so in the spirit section in more
and more complex ways finally doing so
on the religion section and now in
absolute knowing that is what
self-consciousness is doing on behalf of
Spirit In Time
so he he goes on and he says
um
since this negative attitude to
objectivity Stanley kite is just as much
positive uh you know negative positive
it is a positing a zetson it it it's so
don't you know associate positive with
positing they're two different terms
there
it has produced them out of itself and
in so doing has at the same time
restored them for Consciousness I
remember self-consciousness is
consciousness by virtue of being
consciousness
in the notion now he says that knows
itself as notion
now that's where we're heading
what he's going to call a little bit
later the pure notion the highness right
so the notion that actually knows itself
as notion in absolute knowing and has
you know known itself as notion in less
adequate ways in the previous uh places
like in the religion section as we move
through to the the community the
ultimate religion right uh in the spirit
section even in the reason section we
could say so
the notion that knows itself as notion
the moments appear earlier
than the filled or fulfilled whole the
gods okay so now this is a term or
totality is another way of translating
this and you know very important to
Hegel
um by the end we should actually have a
clear I'm going to play a kind of a word
game here a pure a clear notion clear
understanding a clear concept of
wrapping our head around the totality
the whole and our own place in it and
hegel's own place in it right which is
not exactly the same as our own we are
two centuries later than him as I've
mentioned many times and we have to
think if if there's truth in this we
have to think this out in our situation
as well this is going to be uh more
explicit in the paragraph yet to come
after this so we've got the the whole
right
and he says
uh in consciousness
the the whole though uncomprehended not
grasp in a
conceptual way is prior to the moments
so you know the moments where they exist
well this is again also typical Hegel
um you have a totality the whole is
in some sense greater than the sum of
its parts right it's greater than any
one of its parts but the whole exists
because of its parts and the parts have
their meaning within the totality of the
whole and it's the notion that can can
grasp that I mean we can have other
forms of grasping it we could you know
representation but representation is
inadequate too actually doing that
because it doesn't get the whole whole
so to speak right and it also doesn't
situate us as part of that in this
Dynamic
um
relationship of of comprehending
mcgaithen all right so let's go on
so he says time now here's where we get
a very interesting thing time is the
notion itself oh that's great let's just
pause on that for a second doesn't that
sound wonderful what is time what is
human time or history well it's the
notion itself right it's what we've been
looking for this entire time
well he doesn't stop there
and time
is going to have to be annulled or
canceled out but we don't want to cancel
it all too quickly right if we jump
right ahead we lose track of
things we have to we can only get rid of
time or write it off so to speak
when we get to a place where we can
dispense with it so he goes on time is
the notion itself
that is there dot yes right substance is
also there exists
has actuality time has actuality
and we don't want to lose that so he
says it presents itself to Consciousness
as empty intuition right okay so liares
on
these are two different sides of time
and and you can say that this is sort of
like a reference back to Kant but Kant
isn't the only person who's thinking
about time and space as sort of the ways
in which we have to grasp things and
um so uh he says for this reason because
time is the notion that is there and
presents itself to Consciousness is
empty intuition for this reason Spirit
necessarily appears in time and it
appears in time now notice this
just so long as it is not grasped it's
pure notion that is has not annulled
time now and all there could be
translated as written off
canceled out right
so time is as the notion itself is is
how Spirit
Works itself out from being just
substance becomes conscious becomes
self-conscious has a self develops
itself over time doesn't just have a
self is a self in relation to other
selves that's how self-consciousness is
and it does so through time it enters
into time and transforms time into
something more than just time leading us
to the notion but the time itself is
also the notion isn't it just not fully
developed
so he goes on and he says
um
when this ladder
grasps itself
it sets aside it's time form
it comprehends
this intuiting now comprehends
uh but Griffin right beguyved in this
case it's intuition so intuition is
being itself taken in and transformed in
the process it's not just empty
intuition it's not just impoverished
intuition it is intuition that as he's
going to say right in the next uh line
is comprehending griffiness
and comprehended but geifen does it's
doing both at the same time this is a
very very rich
concept the begaf the notion is also
comprehending and comprehended intuition
of what well of this entire process of
itself
of spirit of the phenomenologist who is
observing this
and of us
us onlookers
are part of this as well if we want to
be right
so he goes on and he says
um
here we go uh it is the
outer intuited pure self which is not
grasped by the self the merely intuited
notion when this ladder grasps itself it
sets aside its time form comprehensive
intuiting and is a comprehended
comprehending intuiting time therefore
appears now what a interesting phrase as
the destiny and necessity of spirit
the spirit that is not yet complete in
itself
so as we're moving into absolute knowing
again we're not getting rid of time
we're not getting rid of substance they
are attaining their truest meaning scope
movement whatever we want to call it
and it is we could say it's Spirit
knowing itself through us through Hegel
that is making this possible that makes
it possible for us to go beyond time and
to transform intuition into something
much more productive much richer
so time therefore appears as the destiny
and necessity of spirit not yet complete
in itself the necessity to now notice
the language again to enrich
the share which self-consciousness has
in Consciousness okay so that's part of
the necessity
to set in motion the immediacy of the in
itself
which is the form in which substance is
present in Consciousness or
conversely to realize and reveal what is
first only inward in itself being taken
as what is inward that is to vindicate
it for spirits
certainty of itself spirit is now
self-certain and we had that again back
in the spirit section didn't we yes
but we did not have the Pure or rather
purified purifying
notion or concept now did we
pure here should be taken less as an
adjective
and more as a descriptor of
what it is that the notion is doing and
having done to it having done to it by
what not by time not by substance by
itself
and guess who that
notion is
it's not something out there estranged
from us a beautiful thing that we grasp
it's us
if Hagel is right
and it may very well be right about this
this sort of thing
um I mean maybe we don't even need all
the oh history is finished you know
we've gone through all the shapes of
Consciousness I leave this to you to
think about as we close out this
paragraph can we have this triumphant
ending that we're we're working our way
towards remember this is paragraph 801
we only have seven more paragraphs left
in the entire work
six of which are pretty long and
involved like this one is one of which
is just a short little paragraph right
um
are as we get so close as we're getting
to the end of this could we buy into
this could we get the fullness that
hagel's offering us without necessarily
thinking that history ended in 1807 or
you know 1814 or 18 whatever right
that time still does play
a role well I I leave that to you to
think about and I'll just say that this
is a really important transition point
we have those four paragraphs prior
where we got time and actuality brought
in now we see how time plays a role here
for the end point that we are striving
towards in this work